while science has moved fast in the
pandemic so has misinformation and the
vaccine has often been the target
experts warn fears about fertility are
causing women to refuse the jab
news that over 13 000 have reported
changes to their periods since being
vaccinated have fueled those concerns
for these vaccines we have quite a lot
of evidence that they don't reduce your
chances of getting pregnant
so in the clinical trials people were
asked not to become pregnant but
nonetheless 65 people became pregnant by
accident
and they became pregnant equally in the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated group
which tells us that the vaccine isn't
reducing people's chances of getting
pregnant
what would you say to a woman you know
maybe thinking about having a family
wants to get pregnant hasn't had the
vaccine yet and is really worried about
hearing these reports about people's
periods changing worried about fertility
what would you say to her today we know
that sex hormones affect the immune
system and the immune system affects sex
hormones
and actually one quite good example of
this is that we have some evidence that
the flu vaccine given at a certain time
in your cycle
can slightly dampen the amount of
progesterone you have
and it's the balance between estrogen
and progesterone that builds up
and breaks down the lining of your
uterus so if these get
slightly out of whack then we might
expect to get a heavier period
or a later period when you look at some
of these facebook groups it gets really
dark really quickly in fact not getting
the vaccine when pregnant or trying for
a baby could
doctors warn do more harm so there's no
evidence that the vaccine affects
long-term fertility
um could the vaccine if the vaccine
makes peers irregular for a month or two
could it make it a bit more difficult to
fall pregnant in that month or two well
theoretically possible
maybe you wouldn't ovulate release an
egg in that month but
is that a reason not to have the vaccine
i don't think so because bear in mind
that
if you're pregnant and you get coveted
infection it tends to be a bit worse on
average
for both mother and baby anything that
stops people from coming forward to
vaccination
centers like this one to get their jab
is a problem for all of us because the
government is relying on high levels of
immunity across the country
to move away from restrictions and into
normal life again and to do that they
need to get people to feel happy and
safe
to come forward to get their job vaccine
hesitancy is right at the top of the
government's agenda as ministers prepare
to unlock society
they're relying on it to protect normal
life but it can only work once it's in
our arms kate mccann sky news